EU interior ministers have discussed
ways to crack down on foreign Fighters
with more than 3,000 known to have join
battle with extremists in countries like
Syria and Iraq The Minister's aim is to
toughen laws on foreign Fighters and
improve the way information about them
is exchange among EU member states the
eu's counterterrorism coordinator and
the European commission briefed the
Council on the latest events as these
Fighters could pose a threat when they
returned to Europe also a better manage
of the flow of irregular migrants across
the Mediterranean was a central issue in
the discussion as the pressure increases
in European borders ministers heard from
the commission and the external Action
Service about the importance of
international coroporation to improve
the issue our Target our aim is to
develop a comprehensive approach with
countries outside the European Union we
will also do our utmost to protect those
in transit countries through the
regional Protection Program protecting
the data of European citizens was high
on the agenda for justice ministers they
reach an informal agreement on some
aspects of a draft regulation which is
aimed at improving data protection in
Europe and toughening the way the rules
are enforced it concerned the public
sector and specific data processing
situations because part of the
regulations are interlocking no
agreement on any section can be set in
stone until the entire package is
agreed